this morning steve bannon is one step
closer to her criminal charge of
contempt of congress the trump
administration's former chief strategist
refuses to cooperate with a special
house committee investigating the
assault on the capitol the trump ally
was in close contact with then-president
trump before that january 6 attack the
full house is due to vote tomorrow on
whether to ask the justice department to
pursue contempt charges nicole killian
is on capitol hill with the latest on
this story nicole good morning to you
hey good morning gail if steve bannon is
found guilty and criminally charged he
could face a fine of up to 100 thousand
dollars and jail time for up to a year
an opinion of chairs the eyes have it in
a unanimous vote the house select
committee investigating the january 6
attack approved a resolution to hold
former white house strategist steve
bannon in criminal contempt it's a shame
that mr bannon has put us in this
position
but we won't take note for an answer
during the 30-minute proceeding the
panel pointed to bannon's failure to
produce documents and appear for a
deposition this month his attorney has
cited executive privilege but the white
house and the committee reject that
claim mr bannon's and mr trump's
privileged arguments
do however appear to reveal one thing
they suggest that president trump was
personally involved in the planning and
execution of january 6. the contempt
report alleges bannon appears to have
played a multi-faceted role in the
events of january 6 and had specific
knowledge about them including this
warning on his podcast january 5th
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow according to a new poll about 6
in 10 americans say they consider what
happened at the u.s capitol on january 6
an attack on the u.s government roughly
four in 10 americans think former
president trump bears a lot of
responsibility the former president
called the probe a continuation of the
witch hunt he's urged his top aides not
to cooperate and sued the committee and
the national archives to block the
release of documents house select
committee member jamie raskin does the
committee intend to subpoena him
that has not come up yet but we're going
to follow the evidence wherever it takes
us there is no doubt we're going to get
to the truth of the matter
if the house approves the criminal
contempt citation against steve bannon
it would get referred to the justice
department a spokesperson for the u.s
attorney's office says it will evaluate
the matter based on the facts and the
law tony
keep following it also nicole thank you
very much